[Music]
welcome
sheldon we've been waiting for you
are you the ten commandments no
we are one and zero
we are the binary code that underlies
the universe
the ten thing is a common mistake
i want to understand god can you help me
did you not hear what we just said it's
a binary universe
god is yes and no left and right on and
off
something and nothing positive and
negative male and female
but why is there evil and suffering
without evil and suffering there is no
good and happiness
oh sure binary shall we give him the
final piece of information that unlocks
the secret of the universe
why not at least one human being should
know the reason for everything
sheldon before the universe began
hey dummy you're drooling all over your
books oh
no zero was about to tell me the secret
and you ruined it
i never heard from one and zero again
although i was once visited by nine when
i had chickenpox
he was a lot less funny than he thought
he was
okay what god means to
me who'd like to go first
billy i'd like to go third
all righty who's feeling brave
missy i'll go second great
does anybody want to go first i'll go
okay come on up here sheldon let's hear
what you got
i've spent the last week studying what
people believe
and i've come to a conclusion and what's
that
i'm starting my own religion i'm sorry
what i'm calling it mathology
it's based on a universal binary system
that's terrific sheldon but this is a
baptist sunday school
i know i'm here to convert everybody any
takers
okay let's go have a talk with your mom
the only sin in mythology is being
stupid
[Music]
welcome to the church of mathology today
i'd like to talk about prime numbers and
why they bring us joy
[Music]
hallelujah